he directed train wreck coming out very
soon July 17th
Ami's a highly anticipated movie and I
got to see some of it and it was
absolutely hilarious loved it
and and and I'm anxiously awaiting it
you were directing athletes yeah in this
film you've done this before but like
Bron James you direct LeBron James exact
movie what's that experience like it's
weird because I was so bad at sports and
I was always picked last in gym class
and it makes me kind of hate athletes
and hate just people who are in good
physical shape like if I see a like it
doesn't get make sense
I still hold on to it like I see like a
guy working out is like 40 just got his
shirt off I always have the same
reaction which is that guy just cuz I
was picked last in gym class yeah and
you're always holding your kids hands
and so you know it's weird because I
don't connect with athletes that way but
he's the nicest guy he's very sweet
but I did like to direct him because I
was able to dominate him and it's rare
that I get to dominate like you know
like you're in control Babe Ruth of
basketball and so it was so fun and he
really is hilarious in the movie it's
unsettling how funny we have a clip here
this is a clip that's not even in the
movie this is just them rolling on you
directing yes this is the documentary
about the movie this is how I directed
abroad because he has a very deep voice
and that was causing some problems and
the movie so I had to adjust them let's
take look this clip I'm a little
concerned if you have a deep voice and
sometimes what a voice is very deep it's
hard for people to hear it okay now well
it's deep and so like for certain people
you can't hear that so if you're a
little at higher but can you talk the
way I'm talking and they say say hey
how's it going like like hey how's it
going like
well it's that's intimidating something
all I know you like it scared in the
middle yeah so what I'd like you to do
is this queer do a little vocal extras
okay just to get you stuff cuz I want
you to understand the range of your
voice okay here's the range huh copy me
[Music]
Oh what was it where's this instrument
for that thing right well it's much so
you have much more range than you think
so let's do it together
perfect
[Applause]
wonderful time hey thanks for watching
please subscribe to my youtube channel
so they will stop making me shoot these
videos please